[Music]
what is that you're a good whistler i
love to whistle i know
a lot talked about this that is a
whistle you may recognize
us from laurel and hardy the theme song
they were our favorite
comedic duo growing up they were
hilarious bart's brothers were up there
too but they weren't a duo stan laurel
and oliver hardy uh stan was from i
think ed who cares but he was british
she was from edinburgh i think that's
scottish scottish but i think she was
born there anyway he lived from 1890 to
1965 and i just want to read for
everyone what is on his tombstone he's
buried at forest lawn it says about him
and this is i think the best you could
hope for in life it says a master of
comedy his genius in the art of humor
brought gladness to the world he loved
does it get better than that what do you
think yours is going to be i don't know
if you can dodge a wrench you can talk
maybe you can't dodge death or hello i'm
a pc yeah it'd be funny to get something
uh funny on your
tombstone you know like we were talking
about mel blanc you know mel blanc got
that's all folks or that's that's not
funny there aren't there ones that that
are like i wish i in key west yeah
there's one it said i told you i was
sick yes that's a great one that's
dark and funny yeah but it's like and
you know you could it's a legacy it's a
funny legacy so for the rest of time
people who see that will just assume
whoever's buried there was was really
funny and playful but stan laurel and
oliver hardy were two of the greats we
just want to acknowledge how much we
love them it's not even a story we just
it's a story yeah what you think it's an
acknowledgement
thank you stanley
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my co-host my
brother christian that's your uh i don't
know i don't know ollie ah that's my i
can only really do stan laurel when he
was crying did you ever see the movie
the john c reilly and steve coogan i did
not think i was going to like it
because it's such a sacred thing for me
but i thought they were both brilliant
they sounded they act i mean they were
uh incredible those two spot on
especially steve coogan yeah stan laurel
oh my god it was incredible how he looks
like he was channeling i know it was
eerie well why are we talking about our
love of laurel and hardy our favorite
comedy duo
because yeah our guest today
um some might say we might say
is a modern day
oliver hardy and um his partner
would be uh modern-day stan laurel his
comedic partner yes not his not his life
partner no um uh his comedic partner
simon pegg our guest today is nick frost
he's like you said most known for his
comedic partnership with simon pegg
hopefully future guest of the show yes
uh a a new friend of mine um whom i met
during the pandemic they starred in such
films as shaun of the dead
uh
end of the world
they are um they've been they've been
comedy partners since uh a tv show a tv
show called spaced um back in the there
was like a great there was like a heyday
of british comedy i'd like to see that
i've never seen it i got it here really
oh it's yeah really good um
and they uh and you you see like the
beginnings of a really special comedic
relationship they're just they
complement one another so well uh again
like that's why it's hard to not think
of laurel and hardy when you think of
them and physically too nick's gonna
love this uh do you think he'll be
insulted by the uh
no party comparison
what were you talking about nick is one
of the quickest uh but he's also able to
laugh at himself he's um
he's i i got to do a pilot with him a
couple years ago we'll talk a little bit
about that that failed pilot uh and it
was one of the best professional
experiences of my life i just getting to
be around him i loved his
sense of humor and his spirits he he's
one of those rare combinations of like a
really warm
person you know kind warm person but
also can laugh at anything and is like
ridiculously funny and nothing's off
limits you know he's just one of those
guys uh
i i love him and this was a great
opportunity to just go oh you almost had
i almost had it i uh i couldn't stand
the landing
it was amazing it was like a triple flip
in the air opportunity yeah like tight
you kept your arms close to your chest
and then you just didn't stick the
landing it's opportunity's tough
community what is that unity there was a
jeopardy category the other night that
had uh things that rhymed with utility
yeah utility host aaron rodgers
hopefully his tenure is coming to an end
yes as uh the host yes and coming up
next uh we're gonna have nick frost
that's my aaron rodgers impression
that's not bad it is it's a little
kermit i never realized that yeah um
great football player oh not a great
house amazing you know let's dwell on
the positive he's an incredible football
player and a really nice guy it seems
like he doesn't seem like a nice guy he
does
anyway that's apropos
yeah
uh let's get into it let's get into the
show today um
with that's too carmony by the way aaron
rodgers hopefully future guest yeah but
now what if he hears this he won't hear
this you don't think no he's busy
hosting jeopardy you don't think
somebody who aaron rodgers knows might
hear this and get it back to him that's
arrogant uh anywho anywho anywho uh
harry is god i love his accent too
there's so many things about this guy i
love you're gonna hear how much i love
him and i think you're gonna fall in
love with him yourselves because he's
one of the he's just so charming and
wonderful and hilarious here he is nick
frost life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
thanks for doing this
what you're scrolling uh i'm looking at
um i've just got an email off work and
they were we're we're i think la county
has asked production to shut down oh god
and so it's um
i think we meant to go back to work on
the sixth but now they're saying the
11th
now now that which is
what's that going to do right oh it's
great
it's crazy i i don't know it feels i
mean we've already shut down twice once
because of [ __ ] me
[Laughter]
i was like i got here and
i had a weird thing where i spent the
last two years sleeping on my couch
like lying sideways
looking for like a thing where i didn't
i couldn't i was frightened of going to
a bed why so i'd sleep on my
i don't know there was an odd thing i've
got a weird thing in my mind about going
to sleep in a bed
i could sometimes start off in the bed
but then like an hour later i'd be up
and i'd be creeping down the stairs and
he was like where are you going
but then i'd sleep on the couch but on
my side
nick's doing uh kind of like a burt
reynolds like side pose yeah
but i can't imagine me with um
swimming trunks on them
on a
but now i'm having trouble like sleeping
in a bed so i got like a
i got a masseuse a lovely lady called
michelle to come to the house
before my partner got here and stuff
she had a mask on and i had a mask on
and stuff
and then
like
they didn't tell me to not have a
massage
they didn't so that wasn't one of the
specific don't do this
yeah yeah it was a gray area
and so
like two weeks later i had like two
massages and then two weeks later i got
a test and it was i got i've gotten a
text from her saying
hey i just thought i should let you know
that i tested positive
uh i was like oh [ __ ] i had to say to
production all right listen i should
tell you i've got a massage and she's
positive and now so they have to i have
to go to be on in quarantine for two
weeks oh my god i had to kind of move my
get to move my scenes around so
they had to shut down for like three
days and then i was like oh
oh god but you weren't even positive you
didn't even test positive you were just
they were
yeah no wow i think it's worse i think
it's worse in britain than it is here in
terms of amount of people getting it
versus deaths
there's a there's as many people in
california as there is in the whole of
britain but
you're only getting like 50 people dying
a day but three there's like 750 000
getting sicker days yeah it's like
contagion but your family's there with
you they're into luca lake yeah i got my
i got my partner and our two-year-old
because at christmas i've got my ex-wife
and our 10 year old so we're all in one
big house i'm like some kind of
swinging dick mormon
with all his wives
but they as i recall
they really get along i remember see
they they like each other yeah they're
they're a little crew we're a little
true so
my my son my oldest son and my ex-wife
going tomorrow nick it's the thing
you're doing not you say it's totally
different it's not at all it's about a
serial killer right it's like an intense
i mean it's comedic but in a kind of
really odd way that i've never done
comedy it's like it's like a 1940s thing
you know it's oh oh really
yeah it's kind of kind of like screwball
yeah
yes exactly it's like it's if if you
could say to the main characters in the
first couple of episodes hey you know
what would be good is if you don't go
into that room or don't climb that
ladder to see who's looking through the
window don't do that it would end the
comedy the scene would end
but it's that kind of comedy it's like
well now what you want me to do
but i mean like you know i find myself
like really heightened 1940s
mad men's style
you know i've never had never kind of
had to do that advice before yeah weird
but
but with a serial killer uh
yeah he's kind of fun but he
can't stop him so you know he has to
kill people wow it's like i might as
well take the head off of this one
literally
yeah um
ah poor you uh
but also i'm finding that
i've never had to wear
like costume before like this like
usually i'm wearing like
the [ __ ] i wear to go to bed you know
most of my characters in track suits or
they're like proper clothes
and they look amazing but it's like they
do not suit a [ __ ] big
well because they're like several pieces
i can only imagine the amount of like
high waist and a straight away you look
like an egg
or
you look like uh obelix from asterix and
obelix
um but i just i'd love to see the
document i'd love to see the the figures
and the stats of
um fat man suicides from the 1940s
and and an amount of mirrors sold
and find
find the
draw up the the mathematical equation
what
what are the um i'd like to see who's in
the middle of that venn diagram
and and how and what how confident their
offspring were how secure of a lineage
they had
um
but you wore some crazy [ __ ]
you wore some crazy [ __ ] in the uh in
the huntsman you told me some great
story i think you had just done the
sequel
when we worked together the snow white
movies
yeah
well yeah i mean that was
i mean i think the worst thing i've ever
worn is when i did that tinting film
with
with daniel craig and simon and
spielberg and that because it was just a
like a black bodysuit oh yeah it's like
a onesie like a unitard oh my god it was
awful because it was
i looked like a
like a stegosaurus egg
and you had little balls all over you
and you had to and
little balls uh
you know you could i had a camel toe
but then you know and then james bond
comes on to set and he's got like
his own one that he got made in
you know bond street folks it's also
he's there's no better male form
than daniel craig
i mean he's like he's like a no
but also he's
i was amazed at how just fun he was and
he laughs a lot yes yeah he loved she
was really not like nice
a lot of it was laughing at me looking
how i did but
and what was simon wearing huntsman was
kind of good
well he had the same thing but he again
he just looks [ __ ] cool here you know
i don't close i'm better i mean
i think it's because i'm like
i'm best if i've got like
just a pair of just a pair of pants on
just not just in the woods
well they're hanging up a route
what the huntsman
you told i don't know how many you can
tell here or if you can even tell any
but you had we were talking about ray
winstone and um bob hoskins that you got
to work with like legends like uh
and and um but really
intense
guys right like they were yeah
they're not that far removed from um
from
the characters they played in those
those gangster movies and stuff and
there was a lot sitting around doing
huntsman i don't think they kind of
perfected
how they were going to shoot it before
we started shooting
so i think once we got there they
realized what works best is
they shoot on the doubles you know like
a mid to a wide
and a little they're like little people
little guys
yeah and the little people who were our
doubles were who wore our face masks
and then they kind of got us in at the
end of the day and
and we shot our singles and close-ups in
a couple of hours which worked great but
there was
a lot hanging around in that but
we
me and eddie marzan and toby jones came
up with this kind of thing that
we
we were going to convince bob hoskins
that
contractually
he had to show up to two world premieres
but dressed up like his character
and like with with arriving like a
little cart
and then they had stuff for us to do
like we'd tumble out and we'd have to do
like a little skit and was he and when
was he like [ __ ] sake that's not
that's not true
i'm not [ __ ] doing it
like we do a thing where we just chat
amongst ourselves me and eddie
and
then you could see him why what are you
talking about
and i was saying to him hey bob
i've heard that you got auckland well
done mate you love auckland
he said [ __ ] off i'm not doing it and
then like he looked off for a bit and he
went i love auckland
[Laughter]
it was really weird
but he was really old that was his last
film but he got he did a thing where
we're in the woods and stuff and
eventually it's every now and again he'd
say
go for a piss
and he'd get up and he'd just wander off
into the woods
and then we'd all be sitting there and
like five minutes late you'd be thinking
where's bob
and then from out of the forest you'd
hear like this amazing
crashing noise
and you just ah [ __ ]
and like he'd fallen he just kept
falling over
so he'd come back with like brambles in
his beard and
like it i think yeah he blackened his
eye at one point no no oh my god
but then he had to have an extra go with
him every time he like an ad every time
he get away oh imagine getting that job
the [ __ ] up don't be a [ __ ] bender
[Laughter]
well he it's it was so interesting to me
that he because i
knew him
so well from who framed roger rabbit i
mean that was like um yeah you know from
my childhood and so i had that image of
him where he was a little bit
surly i guess in that like kind of
hard-boiled but not it was like a kids
movie so he wasn't um yeah
it was a little bit lighter but uh and
then i then i watched some of his
earlier movies and and he was uh
i know people you overused this term now
but he was like a badass he was like a
real badass oh my yeah
i used to love that film the longwood
friday that was like the first big
gaster film
yeah have you ever seen scum you ever
seen ray in the film scum no it's funny
you told me to see that years ago uh no
i still haven't seen that it's brutal
it's kind of brutal but that was ray's
first kind of thing yeah but he's like
the thing about bob was
he i you know he's just
there were like a bunch of us
dwarves
and we just like we weren't sure it was
on christian and it was on on chris
hemsworth and stuff so like the director
would be
doing like uh a rehearsal with with
kristen stewart and and
and thought and then ever every now and
again you'd hear bob say let's just
[ __ ] shoot him
like he'd just keep shouting it from
like the wings
he
couldn't understand why we
let's just [ __ ] shoot something
what was that like you mentioned you
were were you a huge movie guy growing
up i imagine you
i mean you talked about
watching movies like that were those
your formative was that your youth was
it spent watching those movies or
so i didn't
i didn't know
i knew what films were i knew there were
films
but i didn't know
i didn't know about cinema i didn't know
that it was a thing i didn't know you
could
like i didn't know your hobby could be
watching things
i didn't know it was
you know there was like
a thing i just like i watched indiana
jones and it made me feel
funny and yeah yeah yeah anything about
spill anything of i watch the spill also
you know when you're like 10 years old
and
your parents like to [ __ ] drink
heavily and your mum's an alcoholic and
they say you can have whatever film you
want on sunday night because we're gonna
be in the pub
it's like
you know and you're watching phantasm
and poltergeist and
things you shouldn't be watching you
know exorcist and
i spit on your grave
oh my god that was that
they were my that was what i did you
know but
wow i was also
like
i was just like i said i had a life it's
like
me and my mates would buy
[ __ ] cars and then
stand around smoking in their garage
trying to make it go again
you know what i mean yeah
you know at 16 i was going to illegal
the first illegal rage so
our life was about trying to find out
where these raids were and
but you know i still
i still felt like
i didn't know what to film i didn't know
what cinema was right i knew these are
the films i enjoyed yeah this is great
and i didn't realize it was a thing yeah
when you when you have that kind of
childhood when you're like talking about
working on cars and finding raids
raves there's probably not a lot of room
to cultivate a
to become a cinephile you know it's not
um
you don't have the luxury of that i mean
you didn't have that kind of luxurious
childhood
um
what was it about yeah it was about
trying
going into [ __ ] pubs
to try and find
five dollars worth of hashish and not
get
cut and
it was that kind of [ __ ] right so you
know when i met simon and suddenly like
when he said to me something about like
john williams's score of et and he does
something
in it
that sounds like a bit from star wars
it's like i [ __ ] i knew that i had a
reference i found it on my own you know
yeah
yeah i didn't realize referencing was a
thing either so when i met simon he
starts to say to me oh this is he's
referencing this other film i was like
but i'd found that on my on my own when
i was watching on mine i was like oh
that sounds like the bit from star wars
it felt to me like you had a real like
encyclopedic knowledge
of movies of actors of
impressions and stuff you told such
great stories
your recall was incredible has it always
been like that have you been like that
always
um i think
i think it's
yeah yeah i kind of have you know in
terms of doing impressions and stuff
like that and i think i went
i was diagnosed i got diagnosed this
year with with adhd i never realized i
had it before this year uh
yeah
yeah
not that it no it's changed my life but
there were things that
changed my life but there were things
that like we talked about during that um
diagnosis that it was like oh okay i get
it you know again
yeah it it gave my whole life in a way
you know
yeah you know i think i've never been uh
formally
um diagnosed but i i would imagine
i'm half the same thing i i
i remember hearing about we were just a
little you're a couple years older but i
we were we just missed the big
uh ritalin boom you know the big giving
kids
diagnosing kids as unfortunately
i feel like i missed it by a couple
years ago
yeah i think i'm sure i would have been
diagnosed as a kid
yeah
and um
but you know i always like the sound of
things like i hear my son now
watching commercials on tv
and he does what i do where he knows
every commercial he knows the
the songs and you know
and i used to be the same that was where
you know i used to love watching
commercial i was really sad when i got
here to the states
for the first time and they couldn't
hook up uh
they couldn't hook up cable in the house
here it's just like
netflix and youtube and
which is nice
but it doesn't have
commercials so over thanksgiving i
thanksgiving off so i went to like
shutters for the night on my own to eat
a turkey and watch the sun
rise
uh and i just sat there and watched
commercials for for 20 hours it was
great yeah even now like on set all the
time i catch myself saying liberty
liberty liberty
you know one that's been in my head that
i find it's so disgusting um it's the
mcdonald's one where they go
i mean it's the da da da da but but some
guy goes he does it in like a weirdly
sexual ways like
yeah
creepy
yeah
there's another one that i hated which i
have to turn off i think it's for carl's
jr
but it's for a thing called a
garlic butter bacon burger
and coming from britain
that noise the sound of those words
make me make me really violent feel
violent
and when the patties like
fall down and gently and like slow
motion flop off each other
it's really like dicks yes yes yes
they're really thin patties as well yes
but they try to make them look greasy
like
juicy and you can tell there's just
sprayed [ __ ] on them i i um
but now i but now it sounds good to me
one of those
i do still yeah yeah i do yeah you're a
real chef like a gourmand you're like as
my mom would say gourmand which is gross
but i've got barbecue in the house we've
been it's like it's funny being in la
because it's like
like we went to the beach the other day
and everyone had like fleeces on and
mittens and stuff and
the kids were in this in the sea in a
thong yeah
yeah out of pong on it was amazing
uh so it's like we've been barbecuing a
bunch and it's it's just nice nice to
barbecue and stuff like really oh yeah
you love you're and you're so good at
that you're so uh
i know you love that stuff are the kids
is it just it's just because you come
from this colder climate are the kids
just like are they loving la is it it
must be so different for them i can't
imagine yeah it's so like my
we have pizza in britain but like we we
got a pizza the other day but it turned
up and it reminded me of et when the
pizza turns up on e.t remember watching
the kids thinking oh my god what's that
what does what are you eating you know
for like a big square box and he went
out and got it he said pizza yeah
yeah so he's kind of amazed by it by
everything also i've got a lot of pool
um
and we got like a half basketball court
which is i'm not much of a baller but
like they're out there just chewing
hoops
they're loving it ah the older one must
have been pissed he had to go back
well he goes back tomorrow but him only
we went um
last week we went to a range and outside
range and shot nine millimeters
i'm real american
oh my god yeah i mean it was
i like i like shooting but he'd never
shot before
and uh it's funny being a dad and and
getting to put your kid through
something you know will
really [ __ ] stress him out just to
see
how he coached with it you know yeah and
it took him like 20 minutes but i got
video of him like having to shake but
then turning toward me and the
instructor with a gun
i can't do it
and the guy grabs him like max holding
his chest he's like
i can't breathe
and then like
he did it he shot his shot
and he got it shot right in the 10. he
was chuffed so like an hour later i've
then got footage of him
merrily loading rounds into an ar-15
quack quack
which is like an amazing thing for a dad
to watch you know
is it like oh he's feeling
himself i mean there's something very
kind of stereotypically
confident you know i think look dad it's
nice to see your kid put himself under
pressure and then there are so many
times
as a person
i wish
now that i thought [ __ ] i wish i'd done
that i should have done that you know i
should have tried to do that but i was
never going to start a finisher until i
was
yeah personally yeah you know i started
so many things i didn't do or i was too
afraid of secretly i was afraid and
sorry nick what's on that list like what
are the what are the first things that
come to mind on that list i know this is
a really stupid one right but years ago
me and my wife went on holiday to oman
in the desert oh wow oh my god we went
from like a driving safari through
like this incredible
dune
scape
and there was a chance but for me to
drive down the face of like a 500 foot
june
and i said i [ __ ] like took it to the
edge
and i said i can't i just can't do it i
can't do it
and then my my wife got in and [ __ ]
did it
and
like even this week i brought it up
uh
because there's like a hill there's a
hill over here in l.a why is the hill
really steep yeah i brought it up twice
at christmas dinner
um i threw wine in my kids face
because of it they mentioned it nobody
say the words oh and man together
around nick
like stuff like that and
well counterpoint you you i wonder if
you're going to say this is that
god what if why put yourself if it's not
something you have to overcome i mean a
physical feat like that to me yeah it's
not like you turned down a dinner with
somebody that that
some notable person or you didn't show
up to meet a girl you liked her it's
like yeah so you didn't go over at dune
i mean you could also been really hurt
yeah yeah
well let me say it like that i mean i
get it
i think though there was a point when i
kind of reached 30 and 35 and
and it also
you know i don't think you should
necessarily judge
who you are as a person based on your
first 20 years or 25 you know it's like
i'm a better person now in the last two
years than i've ever been in terms of
being brave and trying new things and
trying to be a better person you know
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
you had a lot of crazy job i remember
life before acting too you had a lot of
um
just such crazy jobs the things you had
to do
what are what are some of the the ones
that really stand out that you you think
maybe grew your character to the point
where you uh something that you're proud
of
i think well i think being an actor you
know that
and not jacking that in i think when i
when i realized that i was going to do
it and not
because it frightens me it still
frightens me now you know
and it also
it terrified me
never being an actor and then having to
be an actor you know that was
that that was the first time i started
and i was 30 29 30 then that was the
first time i started to think
just to feel what they've grown up in
terms of don't [ __ ] jack it in
see where it see what you can do go for
it you know you've got nothing else
you know which and i really had nothing
else so
that's the thing i mean there was no so
it was was it the kind of thing we're
like oh [ __ ] if you fail at this if you
if you don't make the most of this
chance this rare opportunity you you're
you're conflict
yeah
yeah i mean i was pregnant i would be
the funniest area manager for city
center restaurants
[Laughter]
you know i never i'd have my own company
car
and i'd
i'd run six restaurants in the southeast
yeah
yeah
i think i would have been very good but
then i can imagine me drinking a bit too
much one night
and then falling asleep at the wheel and
plowing into the back of our motorway
somewhere on the m3 before you had the
opportunity was it always i mean i know
you say you love movies and stuff like
like
but was it something that you even
thought was a possibility to do
no again i never even thought that was a
job do you know what i mean i never
looked to watch films and think oh they
were actors like doing a job they'd get
up and i've had breakfast and and i just
thought oh they're in a film
yeah i didn't think they were people
they had to get to work and then they
had to get food and
right that indiana jones like someone
gave him the hat to wear
someone had his like whip in a trailer
yes yeah exactly but like
you know it was
i think i i was just i was a funny
waiter and i was a really good waiter
um
and then i met simon and
he said you know there's
you could do something with your with
your with your comedy you know and so it
was
it was only after i'd i did like 12
stand-up gigs
um
and it was only after doing that and
then doing a bit of tv i thought oh okay
well this is kind of stressful it's not
stressful to stand up
but i let's you know people seem to
like you and and you can make people
laugh and
people are nice and
you know it just seemed to open itself
up to me yeah
so simon was the one that encouraged you
to um
what what were the circumstances i know
you've talked about this um but but
really quickly how did you meet simon
nick um well i worked at a restaurant
called chiquitos in
a place called staples corner which is
in north london
very famous because the ira bombed it
like two weeks before i started work
before
yeah like ira used to bomb london all
the time so they bombed staples corner
so when i went to like have the
interview it was covered in scaffolding
and oh my god plastic and stuff but they
were rebuilding
but i just got back from israel i lived
in israel for two years that's right i
came back and we i was living in this
really
[ __ ] disgusting squat in golden green
above a a jewish bagel bakery
which was amazing because at like 4am it
was the whole
the whole house would fill with the
smell of warmed bagels oh
and i've got a job in like this
restaurant uh and i thought okay well i
don't know what i'm doing
i kind of like traveling so maybe i'll
i'll work here for a bit and then travel
you know i ended up staying there for
like
[ __ ] five years
wow five or six years at this restaurant
it was like
i was really good i was making enough
money
there were loads of
good waiters and waitresses and we
laughed a lot and
got drunk and got high and and you know
it was a lot i loved it i loved working
there yeah yeah it seems like you would
be i mean you're so and then i met yeah
simon and he you started rooming with
simon
after you you met each other at the
restaurant
yeah we did um he was going out with
this girl and and it ended really badly
with her
and uh and then
we were like injured
marmosets clinging on to one another
and like he just
licking each other's wounds
yeah i was like the big marmoset
and then he like clung onto my chest
um
it's like when a mother like when a
monkey's mother dies and then the
zoo puts in like a cardboard torso with
with like a balloon head and carpet
state stapled to the
uh and he was clinging on to that
and then yeah we just started we moved
in and
it just uh
like because he was a really great
stand-up you know i think there was a
time when
i just i would just drive him to gigs so
like we did 200 gigs one year and
sometimes the compare wouldn't turn up
so i'd introduce him and
you know i find out where the gig was
and i'd drive him and and
we just chat in the car you know and
listen to music and
[ __ ] and laugh and and come up with
new jokes
and and then in doing that you know we
met other stand-ups and
people then would get a tv show or
they'd get to be asked
do a talking head on a thing and
you know that's that's then how kind of
space came about and
so space was something that simon did
simon write write it yes did he know
edgar wright separately when the simon
and a girl called jessica um her name
was jessica heinz
uh
her name is jessica hynes a married name
now
um but she was called stevenson but they
um they were friends and stuff and and
and they got to know edgar through like
the paramount comedy channel in london
and the three of them just
got you know became
close and and then they they got this
show you know
and i think i was just
really lucky that
i did this character for simon for years
and years and years just to make him
laugh in the pub and
he said one that we write it in you know
let's write this character and that was
that was it that was how it started
really
oh wow yeah i'm sure you do a wonderful
egg yeah you're right
for like the last five years and now
he's not in l.a no i'm here it's weird
oh he's not well because we hung out
with him briefly i think we went to that
then we went to edgar's one of edgar's
party
his birthday
it was his birthday yeah that was weird
yeah
yeah well there was just i think there
were just so many people there and it
was a lot of um you know it was one of
those things where
that classic like high school hollywood
high school party where people are
looking around for the next yeah
a cooler person i think they've been
hanging with the cool kids and had done
like a vape of weed
and then like
like at the wrong moment they've brought
his cake out and everyone gathered
around him to sing
and i'm gonna be holding my hand saying
hey yeah she's done too much please
don't let me go
like really quietly don't let me go
that's right that's weird
yeah me and
we had uh like when we did the hot fuzz
press tour and stuff like that
we uh i got to a point where people kept
giving us loads of space cakes like all
the time
and space
weeds cakes were weaving and stuff like
edibles
and i i love [ __ ] loved it but edgar
was like he was never a big edible eater
but
it was my birthday and like we were
flying back to london or something like
that and he
he accidentally like a whole edible and
then like became oh god it became like
see-through
he
and we've got like footage of edgar like
sat on
in a plane just
you can see right through him
oh on the plane the whole plane of all
places oh my god
oh
all your stuff together i mean i just
loved so much is he so
it must just be is it is it as simple as
like oh yeah when we get together for
these movies it's just a laugh it's just
like um
it is a laugh but i've got i mean
i don't know it comes with its own [ __ ]
it comes with its own baggage you know
what i mean it's
it's difficult you know i think i've
worked really hard to make something to
make myself be a my own kind of thing
you know i think
okay i beat myself up a long time
am i just at this sidekick do i got my
do i have my own work
do i have my own worth as a performer is
is is there something in here am i
allowed to be
this you know that's why i love doing
sober companion with you because it's
like
this is me this is us you know it's not
it's not within because simon's not here
you know and i think over the last five
or six years i've really worked hard
to to to stand on my own you know it was
also nice to see you because i've i've
admired you as um in those movies and
and as as you say sidekick i never
i i don't know that i would use that
word i i think it's i'd see you as more
of a team um
but whatever however it is however it
must feel to be uh that's my problem you
know i mean that's
that's the chip on my shoulder though
i've given myself that [ __ ] you know
it was nice to see you play a um also
carry something i mean you
carried that story and and uh it was
nice to see you playing like somebody
who was
um you know a romantic and um
like a real leading
man part yeah
you were great but it's you know but but
in doing that it's
i think when you've been friends with
that's why you know it's i always think
when we did the sean of the dead press
tour we did a massive press tour for
sean we did like
26 cities in 30 days in the states wait
nick sorry because because space had
already been a hit in england i mean i
think he had done that thing where it
had jumped and there was a good word of
mouth about it in the kind of college
campus kind of
thing so
they really wanted to push it you know
so we did a massive press tour and
people
people really like the film a lot you
know so but the the day was the same
each day was the same so
we'd get up at 5 00 a.m we'd go and do
you know
cody and the bastard
on campus radio
talking about busted raviolis and
kind of weird [ __ ] ex-hockey players
wanting to punch us in the face for
fifty dollars and it's like
weird stuff and then you go and do like
yeah breakfast radio and press and then
you go back to the hotel you press all
day
then at three o'clock you get on a
flight and you go from
atlanta to [ __ ] cleveland ohio or
you go you drive straight to the
cinema we'd introduce the film
then we'd go and check in and eat a meal
and we'd come back to do a q a then we'd
go to bed and do the same
so we did that for like a month oh my
god but when you're with your buddy i
mean i'm romanticizing it now it's also
been so long since like
i've done that or i've been dabbing yeah
now that to me that sounds like oh what
i wouldn't give
to do listen it was amazing you know we
were all 30 odd and i mean that's 20
years ago so
we were up all night drinking and and
you know whatever and yeah but then when
we did the world's end one a couple a
few years ago
it was like
me and edgar and simon all had separate
publicists we all add our own escalade
we're in several hotels we drive in we
do the q a then we [ __ ] off and that
would be it
you know which again it's like it kind
of suited where we are as people it's
like yeah
i'm not that [ __ ] campus
now i'm i have kids you know i have a
wife and i love edgar and simon and
they're my brothers but
we this is us now you know i felt like
we were like
who who among you on the world zen tour
was like come on let's
let's go out
uh edgar definitely yes yeah he's
terrible i don't i've known edgar's for
25 years and i this isn't i don't think
this is
i don't think edgar's ever stayed in one
night
i honestly don't think he's ever spent
the night in i think he has a thing
where he just has to he's got the worst
fomo in the world so oh yeah yeah he's
always out he's got someone's out i'll
cover something
dude come on let's go look at twins
let's go to quinton
quinton and rizzo screaming death
bastard six
well how does he how does a guy like
that because he must have an incredible
work ethic i just don't know
i don't know how they function i don't
just energy wise just just
physiologically i don't know how yeah
yeah oh he's a little dynamo yeah
he'd be coming down every day during
these press conferences with in the
morning he'd be really white
and his hair was always wet dripping on
his jacket suit
on his suit jacket as he got into the
car hi guys
listen it was amazing it was absolutely
amazing but you know when we're now
yeah fought five and we're doing worlds
end it's like hey you're right how's
your night all right i'm gonna go see
like you know
kind of nice yeah i was also amazed by
your i remember you thinking you had
such a well of
not just energy but like positive energy
like um
you were always game you were always
joking around and and like you said i
mean
really chatty with the crew and i i i
was amazed to hear about some of your
story i mean some of your earlier
experiences and
um
i i i i just wonder if
if having gone through that made you
more positive i mean what is it like to
go do you look back at that time and
think
oh god i i
it do you have regrets do you think
um
[Music]
i'm a very lucky person
you know in terms of to be alive
just to be alive but also to do the job
i do yeah and i get [ __ ] paid great
and people are really nice to me and
i have a nice car i've got a [ __ ]
pool in my house right now
you know
i'm i'm i i'm grateful for everything
you know so when i walk on a set it's
like
i'm not better than the man who
put [ __ ] toilet roll in my trailer
we're the same
we're human beings you know i think i
think
everything i went through led me to that
you know in terms of
we're i mean we're the tip of the spear
but we you couldn't make we couldn't do
our [ __ ] job if there was no focus
bullet
or we didn't have costume you know what
i mean it doesn't work
unless you have everyone
um
was also i think i think as a person
i i
i think i took a lot of it on
and just [ __ ] put it inside me and
left it there and never dealt with it
and
and it just it just rotted me really so
on the outside there was that
but you know there was some comedy that
i did
and for years i could i'd do it to like
make simon laugh or
like make you laugh but i could see that
they weren't they didn't find it funny
but they were laughing it was a little
dark
a little too dark it was always stuff
like
it would always be
i'd be and then i'd say something like
oh ee i wish i was dead
but like in a northern a british and
english northern accent right like i
would imagine like a guy at the end of a
horrible gig on a pier and there's like
10 people in the audience and he
he quietly puts the microphone back on
and he just
i wish i was dead
you know
yeah
that was that was me wishing to be dead
really yeah you know wow
and there was there was a lot of
darkness like that which
it's only in the last couple of years
that i've addressed and thought
that that maybe was me wanting to be
dead
wow yeah holy [ __ ] but you have such a
great sense of humor that you were able
to
you were able to redirect it or or
divert it somehow with comedy that's
crazy i know i was it always makes me
laugh too there's like a thing where
like if just before a take i'll often
not often i do it like once a month or
i'll say something like i've never been
so lonely
i remember you doing that i remember you
doing that
so lonely
but that even that is a cry for help
yeah yeah there's they say there's truth
in every i mean there's
truth in every bit yeah yeah
i mean it reminds me of john larroquette
who would do
not for comedic effect he would just say
do you remember right before we would
roll a take he'd go
uh you know i was in vietnam he would
tell some heroin story
[Laughter]
being in vietnam or you know i was in
new orleans right after katrina and they
were just bodies floating oh we're
rolling i'll tell you right now okay
but you used to do such a good
impression of that it was always
whatever the hypothetical whatever
because then we we
when we were doing the impression it was
always it had to be like a more
graphic or more
chilling scenario
and it got to the point you were so
inventive you were so quick with the
john lyric
but
the funniest part was that we then had
to go do a fun like light-hearted com
like network comedy take and then
i think in hindsight now i think oh
that's why they didn't pick it up
right i know i know
i know well but and yet it was about
alcoholism but it was about um recovery
too i mean it was really more about
recovering uh
and
with pete david i mean god if if pete
davidson had done it now
isn't that funny that he he played a
little part do you have any
recollections of pete
yeah he was a nice guy i remember him
about his dad and and
you know uh he was just he was kind of
setting out there right and now he's
like [ __ ] in snl and yeah he's really
doing any tattoos
that's right i don't think so i just
remember him being really um
eager he was really eager and sweet
yeah
yes and hi yeah
um
are you i did you must be so sick of
this are you gonna do you think you're
gonna do anything else with those guys
you're talking about wanting to forge
your own thing and
uh [ __ ] i think so look i mean i
think it's always going to be there i
think we're going to be lucky i think i
think about this the other thing
it's not often you get a group of people
who start making films in their 20s
and then they keep making them and you
see them and the characters they play
age yeah
kind of what other
you and simon are like manhood yeah yeah
but you know even if it's another
10 years it's like then we'll be almost
60 years old and it will be good to see
how those friends of now now what other
friends do is exactly and it doesn't it
it would there's sometimes there's
something sad my brother and i were just
talking about this something we were
talking about fred armistead
i was asking him if he was going to
revisit any of those characters and he
he um
he said you know there's something sad
sometimes about seeing
a an older face a character kind of
holding on to this yeah young an actor
holding on to a younger character but
but with you guys it's true it's like
it's
your dynamic is not at all dependent on
your age i don't know no i mean i think
it will be like one of us have
pancreatic cancer and the other's white
and we're taking like a car journey from
london to durham
yeah
so we stopped on the way and think about
what happened in our lives
does um
do you have any good let's have a look
at a clip okay
um does edgar know exactly i imagine he
knows exactly what he all of that must
be storyboarded right planned out yeah
he's yeah you know i bet he's
you know simon
because and i have a production company
now uh and it's it's great that we get
to hang out and make things now and yeah
each other and produce other people's
stuff but
we don't see each other a lot you know
he's he's i think he's out of the office
now for [ __ ] 18 months well he does
two missions back-to-back you know which
is great but
trying to trying to find time for from
him
and bits i do and edgar's
edgar's life to try and
get a two-year period where we can oh
yeah they let's do this it's really
difficult but if we want it i don't know
then we will either yeah what um
what is your commitment now on the show
it's just a standard network if it
happens if it goes no listen it's one
season oh wow it was because it's uh
because like the first season was set in
the 60s and the 80s and now this is the
40s and then the next is nobody
so it was once that's the only reason
i'm here that's the only reason
it was like
one year in and out nine months seven
months
wow that's great
yeah it really couldn't be it couldn't
it's
that that that was one of those things
that
like
like the thing like sober companion two
you know yeah there was never a moment
apart from working being with you on set
when i got home at night and thought hey
i hope this goes for seven years you
know yeah i was always frightened of it
i was frightened to look underneath i
was frightened of being here you know
totally yeah i i get it like that's it
was always hard for me to commit to
something like that
but that but doing this job
that was me saying yes to something that
i would have said no to
three or four years ago
through a fear you know
but i didn't because i said you know
what [ __ ] it let's see what dreams
[Music]
hello hello again shaboom and nobody
will meet again
[Music]
i know you were really into raves the
music you listened to is so
i've been to your house it's very
frenetic it's very um
acid techno that's what it's called
that's my um
that's your jam
this
what is that um it's so like again like
i'm trying to imagine you in those clubs
where you you would was it like a was it
just a release was it an escape from was
it just as simple as it's an escape
but this again that is is
there's a quality that that
part of having uh like being diagnosed
with adhd there's
there's a method to that music
there's an order to that chaos that
uh-huh i it complete i get it
i understand how it works mathematically
oh
i know it i know what's going to happen
next
and there's a comfort in that for me
so so what drugs are
i don't want to say good in in a brain
like that but what what were you suited
to what is that brain suited to is it is
it does it want to get it
um
but i was like a rat at raves i was like
a little
like a little [ __ ] head i had like
i once
i was just between i was gonna say
between us but
i used to go i used to wear like sarongs
like just sheets like wrap around myself
and i was caught i was caught years ago
um
[Music]
a bouncer about over a toilet stall
and brought me stuffing pills into my
rectum
guys
michelle are we rolling
michelle we lost michelle
um
in terms of raves that's where that's
where we were you know that was a long
time ago that so that's on one end of
the spectrum and then it's like uh at
the end of the press tour now it's like
okay good night yeah i'm
noticing i've got a small rip in my
tweeze jacket
in the arm
i must remember to ask her to fix that
and so was i left the auditorium that
day
like a labyrinth runs up to me and
smells pills in my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you defog your spectacles
what what um
how did they find i mean how did he see
them
how did he know what you were doing if
you're wearing a sarong
no but i i the thing about a sarong is
it's just a sheet you can just hike it
up you know right that's
true that's why if you are going to
store drugs in your rectum it's a great
article of clothing oh we're storing
them i was taking them out
less
you know less
let's get it
michelle
um that makes sense uh
and
that's that's
so but it was i mean
because i've talked to people who were
like you know either either sober or
they just were straight edge and never
into
drugs but they still love techno music
they still love going to raves there
there are those people who do you still
absolutely of course there are you know
i don't think it would
you can't just be doing drugs
or something and there are some people
who don't necessarily are into drugs but
don't necessarily take them rectally
sure and we shouldn't alienate
there are other orifices available
yeah
and and so you were when you did the
rectal drugs that was you were smoking
weed just it was just a you know that
was our life that was our group you know
there was like
30 of us
and we were rubbish we'd call ourselves
rubbish
and we'd go to these raves every weekend
you know we'd go out friday until
monday night and that was our life you
know just
listening to that and meeting those
people but
you know
i think there was a lot of love you know
and there was also that weird feeling
where we knew people were kind of afraid
of us people wouldn't sit near us and uh
on the tube on the subway and yeah there
was a kind of weird there was a
weirdness we gave off that would upset
straight people which we kind of like
when what are you dressed as during this
time like you're on the subway sorry
that you you're on the tube and
what are you wearing what's the out
what's the outfit
uh i would be dressed as like
um like a giant
hammer
a foam hammer
um
or like
one of the things that runs around the
outfield at a baseball game
you were like furries
[ __ ] yeah so funny oh i wish i had my
bottom heart obviously
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you just froze oh no that was just
me just smiling looking at you
i'm remembering a thing you used to do
uh that that animal now i'm getting i
have such a bad memory but i remember
you doing all these bits uh oh would you
would you like an animal you would get
really like um
i wish i wish i had a better memory
there was just the ray winstone
impression i remember so well um
that i it was such a you were so
brilliant at impressions is there
somebody new that you're doing that you
that you're proud of uh yeah well no i'm
not doing them but i i am like a couple
of years ago i thought to myself
why why have i never done like a david
attenborough impression oh yeah but he's
everywhere you know
yeah
well i spent two weeks just doing
attenborough and i found that now he's a
bit older
he's
he's a lot easier for me to do and i ca
so i do an attenborough now so i do it
on set a lot too to make the guys laugh
i say uh
for these young baboons their life is
coming to an end
but for these birds you know it's just
the way he's
oh that's so good
but for these birds oh that's so good
yeah um
like i like to say things in like
amber's voice that he'd never say like
like like all young worms
these are sephiropods to have to play
like you you say like like ants playing
like these ants are playing with mum
like you give
you give like mammalian
uh
things mammals do to like worms
like an eel like it
will like it'll care for its young for
seven years
yeah yeah like all young cephalopods
these octopus love to play
these scorpions are playing with mum
yeah
i'm also like i do a thing to make my
girlfriend laugh where it's like david
attenborough
he's
he's in a voice-over booth like voicing
the next and he he has like a weird tic
thing where
after every sentence he has to say the
word birds
the guys say
for these young chimpanzees their life
is coming to an end birds
like the guy sorry dave sorry mate you
just uh let me just stop you there mate
you just said birds at the end okay
sorry
for these young chimpanzee birds and
we're standing up there sorry dave you
did it again mate but like it just goes
on for ages
but there's also that thing i do
like where
you hear him in between in the voiceover
booth and he's like really tired because
he's in his 90s now and he says things
like i [ __ ] hate animals
and like he says we're rolling dave
sorry sorry these chimpanzees are on the
side for [ __ ]
uh he says things like i just wish the
earth would die
would you have to go on talking about it
i wish the earth would die
well that's a good example of i mean not
to be too analytical but like
too late but um you were just the
darkness there's a darkness that
everyone smile
oh that's really funny it's also like
it's funny because it's it you just
can't imagine i he's he's always so
positive there's something so oh my god
yeah
i don't want to be around when the
laughter stops oh
yeah um
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say when you're texting
they're sick being sick oh thrall get
thrown up
do you do the green guy getting sick and
then throwing up combo
yeah there's like a smile
in the
funny mouth one there's a lot of okay
uh makes sense if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play i think boxing
oh yeah i mean i'd hate to be hit a lot
but
i mean i i kind of like the idea of just
knocking out a man clean
48 i literally have trouble
going to the toilet at night and not
getting my shorts covered in beers no
one tells you i wish my dad had pulled
me to one side and said at one point in
your life
you're gonna have to wipe your dick at
night
yes
nick it started it started for me that
no one told me that i i know i know i
started and it's funny it was i started
like it started gradually like oh that's
a little droplet that i need to
you know and now it's like i fully it's
just part of the routine
yeah
wipe in a dick i i wish someone you're
right
um let's hear from some sponsors uh if
you could have once if you could have
one snack food for the rest of your life
what would it be
speaking of dick wiping christmas cake
oh crisp oh well like fruit cake we got
yeah like fruit cake with a layer of
icing and then marzipan oh wow
that with a cup of tea every hour
what's your favorite movie sequel of all
time um
sister act 2 back in the habit what's
your go-to karaoke song um i'd say hello
hello by
you
the
beatles
say goodbye
hello goodbye yeah
hello yeah okay uh who was your very
first celebrity crush
jillian anderson
oh
oh there's there was also a time when
you know johnny depp's ex-wife the
french model vanessa parish parody yeah
yeah she had a single out when i was
like 12 or something or 13.
she had a single out called jola taxi
and she was only like 15 so she was like
my first i remember watching her on we
had a show called top of the pops which
was just music and just thinking oh my
god there's a young boy thinking who's
this who's this older woman this
songstress yeah
siren um
if you had to get a tattoo well you have
many tattoos if you had to get another
one uh where would you what would it be
uh have you thought about getting
another one uh yeah i mean i've got some
space here
uh next pointed his forearm the inside
of his forearm
yeah there's lots of [ __ ] i mean
once you get over like 50 tattoos it's
like right
you just it's just a lot of [ __ ] it
doesn't matter anymore
it could be anything i've got like a 38
revolver tattooed on me and then like
the words of mum and dad and cut here
and
four old me
uh just
do you have any funny ones that you got
purely for a laugh
uh no i've got well a lot of i've got
one that says it's coffee time there's
like a steaming mug of coffee and
i've got a weirdly and i've got lots of
weapons which is really
it's only now i've looked back and
thought
why would you get a ballet song tattooed
on you what would you get like a
butterfly knife uh
was that from uh
back in the day back in the rave days
no i've only got my tattoos in the last
six years since
i was tattoo free until i was like 40.
oh oh wow weird and what was the first
one what what broke the dam
uh
like i got um
i've got a tiny little house on my arm
oh it's yeah and the house represented
my mother and the three windows
represented my brothers and sisters who
had died oh that's cool and i mean
and i i'm glad my
death of all my siblings was cool to you
but i left i left a window free and i
also i said like if my dad ever died i'd
have another window put in
and then like he died like a year later
so i didn't have a window put on but i
had the whole garden put in as a result
of my there
wow yeah i think it was that thing that
the death of my dad that made me get
tattoos ah just
it's just a way to turn a mental anguish
into something physical
let's have a look early
okay we're almost done sorry what is
your favorite fruit
that's that's an interesting pivot huh
the death of your whole family
i'd say my dad dying
sorry sorry
uh no i'm gonna say an orange
okay
maybe next tattoo
in the garden you see orange yeah
yeah dad kind of liked oranges
um well what
what do you uh who would you want to
play you in in your biopic in in the
nick frost story
um
me the fly play me that yeah why not i
don't know maybe there's some young
slightly overweight 20 year old now who
in 30 years time once i've gone the new
the frost man cometh
yeah um
and who's your favorite simpsons
character
i want to say
i know it's boring to say homer but i
kind of like homer you know i think we
have to change this question because
that's what this is a newer we used to
say who's your favorite muppet
um
oh um
uh animal
yeah that makes sense uh he was speaking
of raves
he'd be rave um uh dog i think i know
this but dogs are cats
uh cats
oh i'm so that's a surprise
i got cat yeah we've got a cat he's back
in london and he's just
[ __ ] eats me up man that he's not
here
that's right yeah i forgot yet okay um
beetles or stones
um
i don't care
okay yeah that is actually right
i get it you know
i mean
i like the fact i should say
ah the
stones because
but it's like
you know i like some i like some of the
stone stuff but also like some of the
beatles stuff but i'm not
you know if you said to me stone roses
or happy mondays
right right
they're on tv you're on you're at the
your apartment your house seinfeld's on
and friends is on
yeah
what do you watch
i go to bed
okay yeah what about um and after you've
passed away what are two adjectives
that you would want people to use to
describe you nick
um
sorry um let me think i guess
i don't know i don't know i mean that's
not a lightning round question
like i just think it'd be nice if people
remembered me as a positive something as
a positive and yeah and
like a nice person who made them laugh a
bit
yeah well
that's how i'll remember you
okay well that's enough
yeah all right
yeah i'll carry on your legacy i'll tell
everyone uh buddy i really miss you this
was this was so great i miss you are you
gonna be in l.a at any time i'm going to
i think in um
early february i think okay well let's
have a distanced meal i'd love it yeah
all right okay
thank you for doing this man
i love you too thanks for doing this
hearts
okay
all right
bye
so that
happened that happened
oh he's he's it's tough he's got um
what is it i forget where he's from
exactly that is england
right right
i didn't know if it was pennsylvania or
england you're right i think uh god you
are very tickled by him uh i really am
and you know what's funny because i
re-listened
but now would you say re-listened or it
would just be listened right because i
had you listened already no no but i'm
saying when i i i listened initially
when i talked to him it's different is
that not two different types of
listening okay because when you're in
the middle of it you're not i'm not
listening you wouldn't call it listen
you're right okay so when i you're right
so when i listen to it um i was struck
by that that i it it brought me back to
you're right being tickled by him and uh
and it may it may have seen i'm curious
what you're gonna say you're giddy
around him yeah but do you know why
because he's funny well well yeah but he
has the accent no no no spirit but yes
well both all of it but um
he to me is there a handful of people
who are like this they have made me
laugh so hard in the past i've i've
found so much
joy from being around them that now
almost everything they say is funny to
me you know he's like will forte he's
like british will fortes yes yes totally
you know because like they have
community oh no god here we go they have
comedic immunity
immunity immunity but in that yeah
that's true it's true like so it
probably sounded to some people i would
guess it sounded the beginning of that
anyway it's like why is he laughing so
much but i you're like a giddy school
girl around him
like will forte saying he liked apples
was funny exactly exactly something is
mundane exactly and it's because there's
a history of both of these guys making
me laugh so hard nick especially because
i spent more time with nick and um
i was i'm wondering if you're going to
agree with this it's a little chris
farlish where i'm like tell the story
about ray winston you know i like to set
him up because he has
he's just so entertaining to me he's a
good storyteller oh [ __ ] he really he
seems like the kind of person who's
never not been funny yeah exactly you
know like you know some people kind of
develop have to develop a certain kind
of sense of humor and then they
it morphs and evolves and like he was
funny in middle school but he was funny
when he was two probably yeah doesn't he
seem like that kind of guy and when he
told that story about you know meeting
simon pegg and how
he was like i was a good way i was a
funny waiter i was a good waiter
i completely pictured it oh you know
that guy he must have been the funniest
waiter oh yeah but just so effortless
without trying exactly he's so dry
that's what i mean about him then when
he says something sometimes he'll say
something serious and like i haven't
switched gears enough i i
um and so it throws me a little bit
that was funny when he was talking about
his uh
his tattoo and how he he got tattoos
based on his deceased relatives and you
go that's so cool
i did yeah he goes i'm glad that uh
you find my dead relatives cool
he strikes me as someone who genuinely
is grateful and doesn't
think that he is better better than
anybody else and he said he talked about
that how on
sets he's like i i'm i'm realize how
lucky i am to be in the position i'm in
to get to drive a nice car and yeah get
to be treated like this but i don't
think i'm better than the guy who brings
me breakfast in the morning well and i
really believe him i seem and i think
part of that is because he didn't make
it as or become an actor not make it
become an actor until he's much older
exactly he those life experiences he had
helped form him and and uh develop a
sense of humility i
agree i've noticed that where people who
come from more humble beginnings uh have
a greater sense of appreciation for you
know this kind of business
for it being like kind of ridiculous
that actors are catered to in the world
right they are i can attest uh that he
is like that he doesn't just sound like
he's to the point where he didn't even
consider it a a job that people did you
know for a long time he was just like i
didn't think that it was a real thing
i didn't know that he had such a wild
past they're all rave stuff and he story
told about wearing a sarong and shoving
uh
pills up his rectum yeah did you not
know what word to use i know i just
forgot the word he used um he and he
says it so casually does that's the
funniest part he's like right it was
fine in my right hand and you're like
and you you were like um you stored them
up there he was like i wasn't storing
them i was taking them
you stored them up there yeah like a
squirrel it's like locked up abroad yeah
yes
yeah he is so funny god damn it and you
know i wonder what but i wonder it made
me wonder
why
he would choose to ingest them that way
uh well apparently the that area of your
body is very sensitive to a lot of nerve
endings and which is why people take um
wine
enemas
i understand that i thought you were
gonna go and moving on no that was a
funny through line too um
but uh that's like doug's our friend
doug says whenever anything like that
happens he goes
and we'll be right back
i don't know how to say this without
getting too graphic but
but um i can't wait i know that that
certain people
um put
powdery drugs
up their rectum okay what people
humans okay
and i know that that uh stimulates
certain areas you understand that it's
making it sound like you've done this i
have not done this i know but i've heard
stories from um
from humans
but i
but nick said that he put pills up there
yeah i've never heard him so i am
wondering
what the
reasoning for that would be that's why
i've only heard of drug mules doing that
exactly for storing them storing them
which is why i said that i get it like
like a raved out chipmunk
um
i don't know
i guess the pills would break down at a
certain point you know and they would
dissipate into your right but they would
do that if you put them in your mouth
too
but but oh if you want them in that
cavity you want them to really hit you
quickly huh because there's so many
nerve endings there which is why certain
people know
uh certain humans um
in chess but the human you say ingest if
it's going up your butt uh
it's a good question i don't know yeah
but those humans that i'm talking about
put the drugs there for very specific
reasons because they want that area oh
to feel good i see it's not for their
brains like great
that's how you take quaaludes right or
poppers
or crystal meth poopers
for example uh okay okay so you're
you're friends
let's
not friends acquaintances let's call
them um booty bumps okay where did you
come up with that term you just made up
maybe no something i've heard i'll get
from home from a human okay
okay so they do booty bumps or wow
people might be learning a lot i'm
learning a little and i thought i knew a
lot of it apparently and apparently what
these booty bums do is they make let's
just get into it they make that area of
your body tingly feel like
um feel like what a certain part of a
woman's body feels like
if you're following what i'm saying oh
oh oh more more euphoric more uh
orgasmic more sensitive
to certain pleasures okay okay um i see
so it
now but in in nick's case i'm fairly
certain that's not
the end goal he was going for
no i wish i wish i'd asked i wish you
had so if it was a classic booty bump or
i don't think it was a booty bump
it's so funny that you said it's a
classic booty bump
uh wow now i want to know um
i thought see it sounded like the story
he was just trying to get them all in
there to to to get them away from
whoever was about to you were wrong i
thought i know you thought that yeah
yeah um speaking of disgusting things
uh what's disgusting about that you
really lit up when he talked about dick
wiping
that's you were like yes oh my god i
know i know i know i am because it's a
new thing for me gross it's not gross
it's just uh it's gross to picture you
doing that yes it is gross well you wipe
you can't tell me what i think is gross
all right it's less gross than wiping
your butt
you can't tell me that you don't think
it is
you think butt wiping is less gross than
uh no i don't but you still you still
have no right to tell me that it's my
opinion
our parents are going to be so proud of
this conference they might not be
listening that's true hey how about this
uh
this is to our parents if you guys are
listening just send us back a peach
emoji just text us a peach emoji okay
okay right now text us a peach emoji um
you know
chances are i'll have to
dick wipe at some point too of course
you will soon don't say it you don't
know that what's the big deal it's you
just take a thing of toilet paper or
it's not there's no ore i don't know why
i said it or toilet paper
or cotton balls uh-huh yeah sure
it's not a big deal it's just another
step of the process that you have to get
used to i know it's not good thing the
bot body wise things are getting worse
it's just a fact i and i'm not that's
not an ageist claim
it's just it's it's is that your summit
yeah speaking of speaking of getting
worse well i also had the shot my first
vaxx yesterday
uh shout out to my moderna peeps
where my modern uh shorty's at
and um
and i know that you had a similar
reaction worse reaction but i'm i'm
getting uh some
tummy issues
yeah i got a fever on my first dose yeah
fever for uh like 36 hours did you have
modern right maternity i had like a it's
like 101.5 i don't want to scare anyone
anyone away because i think that means
it's working the vast majority of people
i've talked to and read about
uh don't really get a reaction from the
first shot our parents didn't um no one
does it's like extremely rare i think so
that i was one of the lucky ones
no i've also read that if you've had
kovid which i've had um the vaccine
tends to have a stronger
side effect on you uh-huh so i'm hoping
it's just that but i feel okay now well
i want to uh thank all the people over
at a mona terrace where i got mine done
shout out in fairfield you're really
into shout outs like i like a show i've
always wanted uh a i think one of the
reasons i've always liked fantasized
about being on the radio or having a
show like this is i like
i like publicly acknowledging people i
like shout outs yeah it's nice yeah it's
a nice i didn't mean to say it like that
who would you want to shoot don't you
like shouting out people
uh shout out to hey how about a shout
out to uh doug goodman he listens to the
show
i'm not convinced he listens to every
episode well do a test do the emoji test
all right doug goodman my friend
if you're listening to this
right now
please send me an emoji of the flag of
bulgaria
okay that's good uh a shout out to nancy
miss who was uh and all the volunteers
who are volunteering at the vaccination
sites
nancy miss if you're listening to this i
would tell you to text me an emoji but
she doesn't have my number
yet yeah yeah um let's read a letter
okay great from virginia
how would you pronounce this devoir
it's v-o-i-l
and maybe at home you can all
uh perform how you would pronounce it
it's d e space oh yeah v-o-i-l what did
i say i don't know
oh we might need to eat some food
virginia de voir de voice or devoil de
voyo it's a cool name it's a beautiful
name
virginia
uh subject shout out from london oh yeah
real shout out theme
uh hi justin christine and the rest of
the team that work on life is short
christine yep
i'm just reading what i see
it's a shout out well now i feel less
bad about butching her name that's true
virginia de voir
uh it really is the small things in life
that can make a differences and your
podcast has definitely done that for me
the pandemic has been a mind bender for
many people and i can't exclude myself
from that but being me i like to think
of myself as strong and resilient but i
felt kind of deflated recently
in london uk we are in our third
lockdown
man
i've been working remotely since march
2020 i've seen my friends mainly online
and the real brain twister at the moment
is it's illegal for me to travel to my
homeland scotland
and see my family and friends there oh
illegal for some reason this has pickled
my head made me i love the way people
are you know
illegal for some reason this has pickled
my head my head he'd
pickled my head i love that expression
um
my head has been pickled the last few
nights well we've been
anyway made me feel upside down and
frankly not myself i'm sorry to hear
that virginia i don't mean to make light
of your pickled head situation by
comparing it to my own pickled head
situation back to virginia i did manage
to get to the motherland in september of
2020 but only briefly
which i know is better than some have
managed so it's a positive
but who knows when i'll be allowed back
when will i get the vaccine etc and laws
that are different between scotland and
england which is complicating things we
bit
it could be a while
that sucks
uh that's me editorializing i found your
podcast around summer 2020 so i had some
ketchup to do but now all caught up i
eagerly await the next podcast waiting
for its arrival and the familiar banter
and fun conversation god that you know
that's like extra nice to hear from
us i love scottish people i mean it's
nice to hear but from you respect their
sensibilities i do i really do not a wee
bit quite a bit
um back to virginia i'm usually
pottering about well i listen
god is it great your podcast has a
calming effect on me it takes me away
from the pressures of everything at the
moment and i just wanted to say a
massive thank you it helps on pickle my
head some days and that can only be a
good thing thanks once more for the good
conversation and brotherly banter i look
forward to the rest
smiley emoji thumbs up emoji all the
best ginny
god what
she goes by ginny wow how great ginny
devwell oh virginia ginny yeah i've
never thought about that i haven't
either you could be it makes sense ginny
goodwin is jennifer but that's i think
that's very unusual it's very unusual i
think her parents pronounce jennifer g
gina oh that's right gina pronounced it
that way because she's from uh virginia
genie memphis um but what a great such
good expressions too um pick on my head
and uh what else did she say that really
made me smile oh i'm pottering about it
yeah here's a question puttering about
would you say virginia is three
syllables or four syllables
virgin yeah oh because the virginia
virginia
virginia
virginia i guess it has to be four i
think it might be three because i think
that
would be a schwa
right yeah schwa
i never quite got schwab i think it's
bad it's too vile isn't it i might be
wrong two vowels together that makes it
a unique sound these are the moments
that you know when you hear people
uh
speak other languages who who native
tongues or
why am i so afraid to say foreign people
foreigners foreigners does that sound
pejorative i don't think okay but when
you hear foreigners say that english is
a really hard language it's a difficult
language to grasp these are the moments
where i realize what they're talking
about like how would you explain that to
somebody who's learning english virginia
because they would say virginia
virginia
virginia virginia yeah
i guess it's that like a liquid in in
british has uh liquid
new news they have a thing where if you
say that the news it's news not to be a
contrarian but i don't think that's why
the english language is no i know you're
it's more of the grammar and all the
irregularities
all the exceptions to the rules yeah
because every country like
spanish there's there's certain way of
connecting vowels that english has
that's true you know what this is doing
it's
pickling me in
that's a bit it's pickling me hit a wee
bit god what a great accent well thank
you virginia for that letter it was
really nice also uh thank you to the
great accented nick
that's right frost uh frost he can also
do
he's so good i forgot to talk about that
how talented it is that uh accents you
didn't forget to talk about that you
talked about that oh really yeah oh okay
all right good i guess i didn't listen
to that part hmm
um yeah i call back to the earlier
boring part of the show
um
anyway thank you buddy for doing that
and uh and if you guys would like to
write in
we really enjoy getting your emails our
email address from all nationalities
that's right but no mostly scott scott
and canadians in australia
um
senegalese yeah bulgarians what's the
country that um
they they really like it uh they like us
and what what's that country in africa
remember oh oh you know mozambique oh i
think you're right remember for some
reason we're huge in mosaic
shout out to mozambiqueans is that how
you'd say i think so we should know this
we should be respectful of because they
said we're huge most epic how else do
you say it be funny if you go to
mozambique one day and there's like
billboards of you everywhere you're like
you're like the biggest star in most mps
oh my god by the way i'd love to go to
mozambique me too you know both
anyway our email address is life is
short at wondery.com and uh i think
we're gonna talk to you all next week oh
that's right uh hopefully hopefully
something
no no that's not get negative we will
talk to you next week uh and in the
meantime hey this might be fun for you
guys to do uh after you've watched all
of nick frost's movies uh check out bob
dylan's song mozambique because that's
in my head now and um
it might be fun for you to be in yours
good tip thanks uh and thanks to
virginia uh genie we already did all the
thank you we did you right okay shout
outs do we do all the shout outs we'll
talk to you guys next week okay
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted by you
christian long also produced by you
megan monaco another producer on it
senior producers michelle
audio engineer on this particular epi is
sergio enriquez and when it comes to
executive producing who's the guy
marshall louie for wandery
well i didn't mean to do it so quickly
[Music]
hello there life is shorties
shorties for short um i know this is a
little unorthodox we usually have a
pre-recorded voice memo from back in our
from our vaults
our vault but i thought i'd record this
because i've been following signs lately
both actual signs and metaphorical ones
and i thought this was a fun
uh sign following story to share
um i was coming from arkansas
fayetteville arkansas by the way shout
out great town really
really loved working there um the crew
was phenomenal shout out to
all of them dustria and
jeffrey miller of course
and uh everybody who made that
shoot so fun and enjoyable um
and everyone in the town at the graduate
hotel logan the whole gang uh i hope
you're listening
anyway uh i while i was following signs
and trying to do that more because it's
led to some really inspiring nice things
in my life i was driving through georgia
and i saw listening to the nick frost
episode
and i saw a sign for the laurel and
hardy museum in the middle of hey i was
i was uh east of athens so if you know
georgia it's kind of somewhat remote
and there was a small town called harlem
georgia
and they
have the laurel and hardy museum there i
guess it's where oliver hardy was born i
also want to apologize to laurel heads
people who stan
stan laurel see i'm getting more hip and
current with my language um because he
was born in lumberton england not
edinburgh i think he lived in edinburgh
but um i learned that at the
laurel and hardy museum so i want to
thank katie who works there and
everyone in
harlem georgia what a what a cool little
spot so i would encourage you to check
it out and she told me in october they
have a laurel and hardy festival the
whole town kind of shuts down and parade
and everything and if you're new to
laurel and hardy um i would suggest
way out west or flying deuces those were
our favorites growing up and of course
the classic short is the music box where
they try to
push
piano up these steps
it doesn't it sounds boring but it is
what they do with that
that very simple premise is really
inspired and brilliant so i hope you
check them out and um
i hope you enjoy it hope they make you
laugh okay
thanks for listening
you